[Music]
we spent some time yesterday talking
about
the landmark u.s supreme court decision
that basically
caused the ncaa's entire business model
and antitrust violation
and now on the docket for the ncaa
is what to do about the name image and
likeness rules six states as of next
thursday
have nil rules that become effective
i saw this in sports business journal
ncaa president mark emmert
wants the ncaa's d1 council they got
together yesterday they're getting
together again today
emirate wants them to pass rules for
name image and likeness
that will apply to all member
institutions and that will be more
restrictive
than the laws in the six states that
become effective on july 1.
and that is beyond asinine to me and
that tells me
that emmerd who's in charge of this
organization that essentially is
dead in the aftermath of monday's ruling
as it relates to
any effort to regulate and
enforce rules that apply to the various
members regarding what players can and
can't receive it's useless at this point
i think emirates in denial about what
monday's decision meant
monday's decision means the ncaa is dead
it's over
right and they're going to be and
they're going to be more dead if they
try
to restrict the ability of players to go
earn money off of their fame
at a time when the supreme court's made
it clear that this whole ruse of
we have to protect amateur athletics is
just
cover for fixing your labor prices yeah
i i mean
it seems like final like
game over checkmate and like mike
explain this to me a little bit like
so wait he wants to change the rules
and basically what not listen to the
supreme court and change the rules to
make it harder on the people that the
supreme court just ruled on that
shouldn't have these issues am i
understanding that the right way the
supreme court's decision was very narrow
so they can play
dumb right and say okay well as it
relates to
recruiting the schools now
can't be restricted by ncaa rules when
it comes to giving them
something more than the undergraduate
educational experience
laptops other study aids law school
tuition
other graduate offerings other
educational things that they can offer
that's what that lawsuit was about but
the kavanaugh
concurring opinion makes it clear which
way the wind's blowing the whole thing
is an antitrust violation the entire
exercise of saying we're not going to
give these kids anything more than what
we agree the limit is
we set the limit on what they can get
as we rake in billions because
our fans want to watch amateur athletes
they value that which is
just bogus on its face yeah but
but to in to advance that ridiculous
position
they want to have these name image and
likeness rules that restrict the ability
of someone to say i'm going to go sign
autographs and get paid for it i'm going
to sell
jerseys i'm going to sell gear i'm going
to sell shoes
i made the point yesterday arch manning
the grandson of archie
nephew of peyton and eli he's in a
position right now
to start making money if he wants to and
he's got one of the great businessmen of
all time and peyton manning who can help
him
hey nephew come on let's go make some
money off of your name off of your you
are
arch manning and you're one of the most
highly coveted recruits
and yeah you're seven years away from
getting paid in the nfl we can go get
paid right now
and any restrictions that the ncaa
places upon
the member organizations when it comes
to that it's an anti-trust violation
it is it's over and it's only going to
get expensive
and more expensive for the ncaa and
these schools to fight the lawsuits yeah
right
judgments it's i i hope
that this is just the ncaa working
through the five stages of grief
and they will quickly come to the
acceptance that they're dead the ncaa as
it relates to regulating
what schools can and can't do when it
comes to its recruits
is dead good i'm glad it needs to go by
the wayside in my decision and it makes
no sense to me that whole thing i mean
oh wait the supreme court ruled on
something it has to change wait we're
going to make the rules harder
like yeah i mean just that's not going
to stop players from
you know still pursuing you know like
you said autographed things or anything
like that and if they are
you know slapped on the wrist or
put on probation by the nca or something
like that that you're right i mean
that's an
automatic lawsuit that i don't see how
work how it works in the favor of the
ncaa so
i don't know where this goes the ncaa
has bothered me and pissed me off for a
long time
um so i don't know what are we gonna get
into like just the conferences
themselves kind of governing and ruling
well
yeah but but if the conference has come
together yeah and set rules that's an
anti-trust violation too each school's
got to come up with his own rules
somebody asked me yesterday what advice
would you give a coach as to the advice
that he should give his players
the advice is mind your own day in
business it's not your business your
business isn't what these guys do
if they have a separate business that
they're creating where they're making
money off of their fame
that's not your business stay out of it
and i think that's what these schools
should do
and it's definitely what the ncaa should